howdy I'm will Ryan I'm with will Ryan
on the cactus County Cowboys and
actually we're all here so I'll explain
what I do I play the humidify in the
band
I also play guitar and a few other
things and that's what I do that's the
short version here's the short version
of what this guy does his name is John
Reynolds hi I'm John Reynolds this is my
cowboy this is my guitar and banjo and
I'll be playing the guitar and banjo
mandolin and mandolin a little bit but
not here just clean it tonight
and over here benedict brighter yellow
they of course you know there's a violin
as a fiddle in our country band and here
it is and you know so we can do larger
and stuff and some romantic numbers too
because it's still our love you know
their love scenes in the movie romantic
scenes and speaking of loveliness over
here on base we have Katy kuvira I play
string bass in the band yep she gets
slap-happy sometimes over here on the
piano why it's it's demora that's me I'm
being more the rootinest tootinest piano
player that played silent movies on the
range so it's a good old piano and plays
a little bit like wow and he could play
a waltz in a waltz and speaking of
waltzes there's Randy waltz right over
there on percussion
this is a real Indian guides TomTom and
I'll be playing accents during the show
and I have other things like whips and
gunshots and holophone things like that
snare drum
floor tom cymbals have little accents
you know make it cool make it really
come out and alive so is that good
though my name is Randy waltz thank you
yes and finally last but not least we'd
like to introduce Oscar
first time we ever played that
you